Salut, j'espère que vous allez bien depuis deux jours, et que vous commencez de profiter de vos vacances.
Si vous êtes en vacances.
Aujourd'hui loin de moi l'idée de concurrencer Jonathan de la chaîne du Tatou
mais je vais vous expliquer une petite expression.
Et au cours de l'été, il y a 4 expressions que je vous expliquerai.
D'ailleurs ce n'est pas vraiment une expression, c'est un mot, c'est le "pique-nique".
Comme cet été, vous allez sûrement ou peut-être, ou peut-être pas... faire des pique-niques
Je trouvais ça intéressant de parler de l'origine du mot.
Parce que le mot "pique-nique", c'est très vieux, ça remonte au moins au 17 ème siècle.
Peut-être même un peu avant.
Et au tout début "pique-nique", ça ne veut pas forcément dire un repas dehors.
Ca veut dire prendre un repas un peu simple en tout cas sans prétention ou chacun peut amener quelque chose.
Dans "pique-nique", on entend deux choses.
Il y a "pique" et il y a "nique".
On va d'abord parler de "pique".
"Pique", ça vient du verbe piquer, qui veut dire picorer, butiner un petit peu.
Et donc de "nique".
Alors "nique" n'a aucun rapport avec le verbe niquer, tel qu'on l'emploi aujourd'hui.
Il n'y a rien de sexuel, désolé.
A l'époque le terme nique, désigne quelque chose qui n'a pas vraiment d'importance.
Qui n'a pas beaucoup de valeur.
Donc on ne disait pas "un pique-nique", mais "unE pique-nique".
Ce qui signifie littéralement, faire un repas avec des amis, ou chacun apporte quelque chose, ce sont des petits rien sur lesquels on va picorer à droite, à gauche.
Et ensuite on s'est fait volé par les anglais au 18 ème siècle
qui ont pris le mot qui l'ont appelé "picnic",
P-I-C-N-I-C
qui est devenu du coup masculin à l'époque quand il est revenu chez nous
et au 18 ème quand les anglais ont pris le mot, c'est là que ça a commencer à vouloir dire prendre un "repas à l'extérieur".
J'espère que ça vous a plu.
N'oubliez pas de liker et de vous abonner.
Je vous rappelle que jusqu'au 30 août on fait une vidéo tous les deux jours sur un petit truc comme ça, rapide pour l'été.
Pour se détendre.
Donc rendez-vous après-demain.
Ciao !
[musique]